con mares agitados que ya golpean la
costa oriental de madagascar
los residentes se preparan para el
ciclón bats yeray y buscan donde pasar
la tormenta con seguridad
vivimos en una casa de madera la
reforzamos con sacos de arena pero no
estamos seguros de que aguante así que
nos vamos a ir donde unos familiares que
viven en una construcción más estable en
algunos de nuestros familiares ya se han
ido a un refugio de emergencia si el
tiempo empeora también nos iremos los
meteorólogos prevén fuertes vientos de
más de 200 kilómetros por hora y
advierten que las olas podrían alcanzar
hasta 15 metros de altura las naciones
unidas dicen haber intensificado los
esfuerzos de preparación ha ayudado a
abrir centros de evacuación y entregado
provisiones las organizaciones de
asistencia advierten que la tormenta
supone un riesgo para casi 4 millones y
medio de personas
creemos un impacto significativo en las
poblaciones de madagascar incluso en las
zonas que aún se están recuperando de la
tormenta tropical ana a finales de enero
la tormenta tropical ana trajo fuertes
lluvias que provocaron inundaciones
generalizadas en madagascar lo que cobró
la vida de más de 50 personas y dejó a
miles sin hogar